[Musik]
[Applaus]
diese kinder werden eines tages zu den
reichsten menschen der welt gehören
ich möchte gern mal im unterstufe
lehrerin werden
ich möchte tierärztin werden auch
tierärzte hier erst die tierärztin die
letzten werden
in einer bank arbeiten was möchtest du
in dieser bank machen
mal abgesehen von den fußball profis
verdienen angestellte in der schweiz mit
die höchsten gehälter der welt das
monatliche bruttoeinkommen beträgt
umgerechnet 6.000 655 euro in österreich
mit 3724 und deutschland mit 3500 35
euro sind die durchschnittsgehälter
wesentlich tiefer
[Musik]
noch eindrucksvoller sind die zahlen
wenn man das vermögen genauer anschaut
gemessen am durchschnittlichen
nettovermögen pro erwachsenen ist die
schweiz das reichste land der welt
[Musik]
gemäss global wealth report der credit
suisse von 2009 10 betrug das median
vermögen in der schweiz pro kopf 227
1891 us dollar
in österreich waren es 94 1070 und in
deutschland 35 1313 us dollar
[Musik]
wir haben keinen zugang zu mehr
wir haben keine bodenschätze aber wir
haben unseren wohlstand hart erarbeitet
vielleicht hat die schweiz einfach glück
gehabt sie waren nicht in kriege
verwickelt oder wichtige erklärung ist
die lage für mich erklärt dieser faktor
zu 90 prozent den reichtum der schweiz
man heute von dem reichtum spricht dann
wurde der zum größten teil schon im
neunzehnten jahrhundert angelegt es gibt
nicht in einen wichtigsten grund für den
reichtum der schweiz man muss
differenzieren und machen sie die gründe
an verschiedenen orten suchen
die welt ist zu komplex für einfache
antworten in diesem film wollen wir ein
wenig licht ins dunkel bringen
wir hinterfragen mythen und vorurteile
und stellen die thesen vor die uns am
meisten ein leuchten oder überraschen
wie zum beispiel die blaue bananen
[Musik]
die schweiz ist heute reich weil sie
seit langem teil des europäischen städte
gürtels ist er sich von norditalien bis
england streckt man etwas die blaue
banane und es ist wirklich erstaunlich
diese planung ist eigentlich seit 1000
jahren das wildkraut der europäischen
wirtschaft und wird es sicher auch
bleiben dort sind die meisten
erfindungen haben stattgefunden dort
leben die meist leute wenn man die
bevölkerungsdichte und die schweiz war
immer teil dieser blauen banane und
deswegen war es immer teil dieser
wachstumsregion die auch im globalen
maßstab zurück der einzigartig ist die
blaue banane ist ein modell aus dem
jahre 1989
der franzose roger burnett zeigt darin
den wirtschaftlich erfolgreichen raum
auf der sich von england über die
benelux länder west- und süddeutschland
die schweiz bis nach norditalien
erstreckt
[Musik]
man ist selber teil ist diese
dynamischen wirtschaftsregion
eingebundenen sehr dynamischen
wirtschaftsprozess von ideen der
austausch technologien übernimmt dann
weiterentwickelt exportieren kann und
frauen kann auch in eine arbeitsteilung
eintreten das hilft ihm sich zu
verbessern sich zu spezialisieren
und so sehen wir heute die schweizer
gebiet haben sehr klare stärken das land
zum beispiel firma zürich ist sehr stark
in der informatik bankenwesen sozial den
textil zentrum das in sehr lange
tradition die sich dann zeigen
einleuchtend geht es trotzdem
wieso ist die schweiz dann reicher als
ihre direkten nachbarländer deutschland
ist unfair werde ich jetzt durch
baden-württemberg
das wäre der richtige vergleich beim
vergleich mit deutschland muss man
einfach immer berücksichtigen dass ein
land hat etwa 80 millionen schweizer
etwa auch millionen
es ist viel einfacher ein kleines gebiet
zur verwaltung weiter zu entwickeln das
ein großes land dass historisch ein
enormes gefälle hat zwischen ost und
west nicht erst seit er in der sondern
das gibt es ins mittelalter zurück
buchdruck und den eintritt nicht in
mecklenburg
[Musik]
deutschland österreich und die schweiz
sind unterschiedlich stark in dieses
modell eingebunden
während fast die ganze schweiz teil der
blauen banane ist sind es in deutschland
vor allem die gebiete im westen und
zügen österreich wird nur im westen von
der blauen banane gestreift wir sind
hier wahrscheinlich die privilegierten
büro wir haben ausgezeichnete
bedingungen london und salzburg wohnt in
stuttgart oder in zürich spielt keine
rolle
warum ist die schweiz erreicht was
denken sie
sie dürfen frei von der leber weg
also ich kann mir nur sagen das was ich
höre dass es ausländer gibt die ihre
konten in der schweiz haben das ist
glaube ich das was einst als erstes
einfällt zum einen die banken dadurch
die banken
er hat sie immer wieder gehört wie den
nummernkonten und also schon man
schleppt das geld wahrscheinlich dorthin
der mann mit dem koffer der mann ist
ausländer im aktenkoffer hat er geld
sein ziel eine schweizer bank was
bedeutete das bankgeheimnis sehr viel
europäisches geld dass deutschland
frankreich italien spanien oder
großbritannien war auf schweizer banken
hinterlegt wir schätzen dass 80 prozent
nicht an die nationalen steuerbehörden
gemeldet wurden insgesamt über
eineinhalb millionen allein europäisches
geld aus der ganzen welt waren es über
zwei billionen lateinamerikanisches geld
geld aus dem nahen osten und asien aber
auch aus russland war hauptsächlich aus
politischen gründen hier kombis aus
angst im heimatland konfisziert zu
werden wurde aus angst vor regime
wechseln oder kriegen es gab fast keine
alternativen weil andere finanzzentren
weniger unabhängig waren weniger neutral
oder auch weniger professionell
die schweiz hatte diese unglaubliche
position mindestens 40 jahre inne
at least for teens es war einmal ein
bankgeheimnis
es wird wohl bald zu grabe getragen die
usa und später auch der europäischen
länder setzen die schweiz unter druck
[Musik]
seit 2009 gilt das bankgeheimnis
praktisch nur noch für schweizer bürger
die ganze geschichte ist für uns alle
alles andere als einfach das können sie
mir glauben international sind die
schweizer banken heute größtenteils zu
transparenz verpflichtet
was auch immer die bevölkerung sagt das
paradoxon der schweizer politik ist dass
die direkte demokratie immer an zweiter
stelle kommt der druck der supermächte
der die schweiz von außen bedroht ist
immer stärker als die steuervermeidung
politik höchst politisch und gefährlich
wurde und man fast einen krieg riskierte
mit den usa oder den europäischen
ländern
da hatte die schweiz keine andere wahl
als das zu tun was die supermächte
verlangt
es wurde für ein kleines land das keine
atommacht ist unmöglich ein
steuerparadies zu sein
die verbindung zwischen atommacht und
steuerparadies ist eine perfekte
korrelation als kleines land musst du
dich von diesem geschäft zurückziehen
das ist besser
die bedeutung des finanzsektors ist in
der schweiz gross 2009 betrug der anteil
an der gesamten volkswirtschaft knapp
elf prozent
zehn jahre später also nach ende des
bankgeheimnisses immer noch knapp zehn
prozent zum vergleich in deutschland ist
der finanzsektor mit 3,9 prozent weit
weniger wichtig die fetten jahre sind
vorbei
die schweiz befindet sich in einem
normalisierungsprozess es tut mir leid
das zu sagen aber es ist wahr und ich
übernehme die verantwortung für diese
vorhersage das bruttoinlandprodukt pro
kopf wird in den kommenden jahren sinken
die bedingungen sind schlicht nicht mehr
gegeben wie sieht die schweiz nach ende
des bankgeheimnisses aus
nicht alle experten sehen die zukunft zu
düster ich bin überzeugt dass die
schweiz weiterhin sehr attraktiv und
stark sein wird wirtschaftlich und dass
man diese bedeutung des bankgeheimnisses
stark relativieren muss zeigt sich jetzt
dass bei kranken eines mehr oder weniger
weg und ich sehe jetzt keine frage ist
es gerade die region zürich blüht neu
auf weil nun endlich andere branche
platz haben man muss immer aufpassen das
hat eben auch kosten wenn etwas zu
leicht gerät dieser art monopolstellung
dann wird eine gage erträge sie verpasst
innovation um verloren was man auch
sehen muss auf dem arbeitsmarkt haben
die bank sehr viele gute leute aus
anderen branchen abgezogen weil sie
einfach viel höhere löhne bezahlen das
habe ich selber erlebt also gut
ausgebildete ingenieure der eta aus dem
plötzlich bei der migros bald gewesen
das ist natürlich volkswirtschaftlich
besonders ergiebig und einfach so geld
entgegennehmen anlegen das ist nicht was
ein land dauerhaft reich macht es hat
uns zum teil viel mehr geschadet als
genützt
[Musik]
was also haben wir bis hierhin gelernt
das bankgeheimnis ist das erste was
vielen menschen in den sinn kommt wenn
man über den reichtum der schweiz
spricht natürlich stimmt die these dass
es einfluss hat auf den schweizer erfolg
jedoch scheint er über lange sicht viel
kleiner zu sein als man landläufig
vermutet
[Musik]
einen ungleich größeren einfluss
erscheint uns hat die geografische lage
mitten in europa ein glücklicher
startvorteil auf dem die schweiz dann
aufbauen konnte wie sah die schweiz
überhaupt aus vor mehr als 700 jahren
der rütlischwur von 1291 ist ein
gründungsmythos die heutigen kantone uri
schwyz und unterwalden versprechen sich
gegenseitige unterstützung
immer mehr städte und regionen verbünden
sich in jenen zeiten ein außenpolitisch
anerkannter staatenbund existiert aber
erst ab 15 113 die geburtsstunde der
alten eidgenossenschaft die
nachfolgenden jahrhunderte sind
kriegerische zeiten die eidgenossen
erweisen sich als besonders zähe kämpfer
gegen die habsburger und bewundert schon
bald gelten sie als unbesiegbar und sind
fortan als söldner serbe gibt das selber
tun waren sie wichtiger wirtschaftszweig
für die schweiz
junge männer vom land wochen einer der
wichtigsten rohstoffe der mann hatte den
mann exportieren konnte die dänen die
landwirtschaft hier nicht absolvieren
konnte und das haben sich mit den
fremden soll diensten haben sich viele
leute hier sehr viel geld verdient es
gab die leute die solche kampagnen
gebildet haben und die ins ausland
vermittelten die dafür bezahlt wurden
die wurden leicht mit diesen geschäften
aber auch eigentlich dieser jungen
männer selbst das war relativ lukrativ
sicher ins ausland zu verdingen aus dann
eine pension zu bekommen dass man weiter
gekommen als wenn man ziegen getötet hat
auf dem berg
[Musik]
das sollte man eine wichtige grundlage
für die spätere entwicklung der schweiz
zum einen hat es mitgeholfen dass
familien große vermögen bilden konnten
zum anderen haben diese 350 bis 500.000
soll dies über die paar jahrhunderte in
welt gab haben die ja auch dann später
kommerzielle geschäftige tätig einige
haben sich durchaus transformiert in
kaufleute die dann eben aus dem soll
dienst wesen heraus absatzkanäle für
waren aus der schweiz erschossen haben
der handel war eine internationale
angelegenheit wird unsere vorstellung
von das erst im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
die internationale handelsketten
irgendwie aufgebaut worden ich meine cd
schlicht falsch das funktioniert schon
vorher
ich war jetzt natürlich vorteile sie ist
am frühesten gelegen und zwar zwei sehr
wichtige schlüsselrolle und rhein und
der zweite große vorteil sind natürlich
die presse die pressionen dafür gesorgt
dass es sich durch zwei drei vier große
übergänge zwischen norditalien und dem
nördlichen teil europas zwangsläufig
oder der handel kanalisiert und ist eine
der neuheiten schweiz durchgegangen oder
sogar durch diese gebiete
auch der bau von tunnels und der
eisenbahn wirkten sich positiv auf die
schweizer wirtschaft aus und das nicht
nur wegen des erleichterten transport
von menschen und waren für diese
großprojekte waren auf immense summe
notwendig dies beflügelte die schweizer
kreditwirtschaft somit das bankenwesen
der mangel an eigenen rohstoffen war nie
ein hindernis für den wirtschaftlichen
erfolg der schweiz und hat keine
rohstoffe wie öl kohle eisen oder nur in
geringem maße aber zeigt da ich die
moderne literatur sehr gut dass wenn man
zu viele rohstoffe hat ist das eher ein
problem der clio saudi arabien sehr
schwierig neben der neue sektor eine
gute wirtschaft aufzubauen
in europa was nicht nur für die schweiz
speziell ist dass audi die zielgebiete
sehr früh versucht haben eben rohstoffe
zu fred und damit die wertschöpfung zu
erhöhen zu exportieren sich zu
spezialisieren
das ist was länder reich macht
der anteil der wichtigsten branchen am
bruttoinlandprodukt setzt sich wie folgt
zusammen
den größten anteil hat die herstellung
von waren mit 18,7 prozent
handel und reparatur machen 14,8 prozent
aus wobei der rohstoffhandel eine große
rolle spielt banken und versicherungen
haben einen anteil von zehn prozent
einen überraschend kleinen anteil hat
mit 29 prozent der tourismus
[Musik]
die schweiz hat zu beginn diese
ausländer unsere berge liebten
willkommen geheißen
zwar nicht sehr mit großem herzen wenn
man den alten geschichten glaubt aber
sie hat schnell gemerkt man kann auch
mit diesen beim menschen gutes geld
verdienen und die sind wohl gar nicht so
freundlich waren trotzdem gekommen es
gibt hierzu einen schönen witz ein
engländer hat im berner oberland nach
einer langen wanderung stand er vor
einem bergsee
er zog sich aus bis auf die unterhose
schwamm in die mitte zwei bergbauern
kamen sahen dies und dann bekam er einen
krampf unterschrieb hält hält und das
sagte der eine bauer zum anderen du der
da in der mitte
er hätte auch besser schwimmen gelernt
aus englisch und trotzdem ist dieser
sektor wichtig geworden er beschäftigt
über vier prozent der beschäftigten und
trägt knapp drei prozent zum
bruttosozialprodukt bei
[Musik]
den größten anteil am
bruttoinlandprodukt der schweiz hat das
produzierende gewerbe maschinenbau und
pharmaindustrie sind hierbei zugpferde
interessant ist dass beide branchen auf
den selben ursprung zurück gehen
die textilindustrie
sie ist schon vor der industrialisierung
motor der schweizer wirtschaft in der
schweiz setzte relativ früh eine brutto
industrialisierung ein niemandem sagt
das ist die industrialisierung vor der
public industrialisierung es ist
heimarbeit mit einem verlagswesen den
verkehr wieder auf der landschaft herum
zogen und die rohstoffe verteilten die
endprodukte einsammelten das war eine
wichtige erwerbsquelle in einzelnen
regionen im nachbar arbeitet in einem
alten haus die weberin
aus 1000 stoffresten macht sie die
farbenreichen teppiche die unseren der
fehler so gut gefallen haben
es war eine gute möglichkeit in den
wintermonaten noch zu arbeiten wenn die
landwirtschaft also keine arbeit oder
weniger arbeit bot es war ein guter
zuverdienst weil die landwirtschaft zum
teil nicht so viel ab warf die
textilindustrie warm
der lite sektor der ganzen
industrialisierung sehr viel haben
unternehmen begonnen maschinen
herzustellen
gegen diese mechanisierung der
textilindustrie voran liegen
ganz ähnlich wie beim alten spinnrad
wird die flocke ausgezogen
und wie menschen hinter einstmals
gesponnen arbeiten heute zahlreiche
unendlich fein konstruierter maschinen
mit tausenden von spindeln rascher
geknackt rationell weiter taut es ja
auch die textilien zu färben das ist
dann die ta farbenindustrie aus der
entstand die moderne chemie der farben
hatten auch medikamentöse wirkungen wie
man herausfindet daraus entstand dann
die pharmazeutische industrie
was die energieversorgung anbelangte
waren diese flussläufe in der schweiz
wichtig man hat turbinen generatoren
elektromotoren herzustellen begonnen
eine aufstrebende industrie branche die
damals wenn spitze war und so vertreten
sich in dieses globale geschäft in den
weltmärkten einklinkte die
textilindustrie sorgt für einen
regelrechten industrialisierung schuh
schon mitte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
ist die schweiz nach england das am
stärksten industrialisierte land europas
begünstigt wird diese rasante
entwicklung durch einwanderung im 16 und
17 jahrhundert erreicht eine
protestantische flüchtlingswelle das
land vor 300 jahren war es dass sich
eine viertelmillion menschen auf den weg
machte einen unsicheren und gefährlichen
weg von fluchthelfern über verschneite
alpenpässe geführt in frachtschiffen
versteckt übers meer ständig bedroht von
den häschern des königs der das kapital
das die sogenannten bedeutet trotz allem
nicht ziehen lassen wollte die ihr
wissen ihre fähigkeiten ihr geld die
hugenotten waren glaubensflüchtlinge die
in diesem katholischen frankreich zuerst
toleriert und dann aber verjagt wurden
um zu lebensgefahr in die schweiz kam in
der schweiz war das durchaus eine
größere sache die dazu geführt hat dass
ganze dörfer dann den einwohner bestand
kurzfristig fast verdoppelten
viele dieser nutzen waren aber und
nämlich begabt das waren häufig gute
handwerker kaufleute die brauchten neue
fertigkeiten und sie anfragen auch
beziehungen zu rohstoffen absatzmärkten
die umgebauten haben die uhrenindustrie
gebraucht in der westschweiz und in der
deutschschweiz von sicherlich sowohl sei
denn die beantwortung vorbereitung
gebraucht textilindustrie und
uhrenindustrie
das waren in der frühen neuzeit die
großen pfeile der industriellen
entwicklung und das kommt zu einem ganz
wesentlichen teil zur stundung diese
einwanderung
die schweiz verlange eigentlich ein
auswanderer und muss man sagen wir sind
glaube ich 18 80er jahre sind mehr leute
ausgewandert als eingewandert und das
hat dann geklärt
die einwanderung wurde dann wichtiger
und man kann schon sagen die die schweiz
hat unter dem strich profitiert davon
es gab dann immer wieder wellen von
abschottungstendenzen wie wir sie bis
heute kennen
[Musik]
unter dem strich war natürlich aber
genau dass die die enorme
wirtschaftliche verflechtung aber auch
der import von know-how zu einem von
erfahrung von wissen dass sogar selbst
wenn wir die sogenannten niedrige
einwanderung nehmen oder leute die sich
hier ein besseres leben erhoffen die
sind meist sehr motiviert und haben sich
hier dann etwas
[Musik]
die wir bislang gesehen haben ist die
schweizer wirtschaftsgeschichte eine
fast schon märchenhafte erfolgsstory
doch wo licht ist ist meist auch
schatten erfolgsmodell ist eine selbst
nobilitierung man beweihräuchert sich
und sagt wir haben es aber sehr gut
gemacht jetzt kann man mal zuerst auf
die verteilungsfrage achten dann sieht
man dass das was als schweizerisches
erfolgsmodell gepriesen wird eben
keineswegs für alle so aussah wie man
gerade die arbeitsmigration da zeigt
sich diese berechnung wenn die kann
natürlich in die schweiz weil das ein
attraktiver werkplatz war was sie da
aber vorfanden das war sehr häufig
arbeitsausbeutung schlechte
anstellungsbedingungen sie wollten auch
ausgenutzt und das werde ich jetzt nicht
einfach so wie wegstreichen als core
schaden am rande der großen heerstraße
des fortschritts sammeln das würde ich
sehr viel ernster nehmen musste mit
eigener und im wettbewerb stehen diese
englischen ferien hatten viel bessere
technologien zunächst und man konnte
euch
nur überleben und exportieren wenn man
die lohnkosten zählt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
in den fabriken arbeiteten auch kinder
und vor allem frauen frauenarbeit wurde
ohnehin sehr schlecht bezahlt
zusätzlich sorgte die dichte besiedelung
immer für nachschub an billigen
arbeitskräften
das war auch eine direkte kopplung von
weltmarkt um dorf die leute die familien
trugen das volle risiko wenn das
geschäft nicht mehr lief eine globale
wirtschaftskrise ein trotz das war's
dann im neunzehnten jahrhundert immer
mehr der fall
dann mussten sie eigentlich von etwas
anderem leben können einige konnten das
weiß immer noch so kleine land
wirtschaftsgüter hatten andere kommen
dann in dieses große elend das waren
dann hunderttausende die noch mal hin
neunzehnten jahrhundert auch den weg
über den atlantik fanden
wer genau ist reich das war schon um 18
50 nicht so ganz klar das sind noch
heute verhungert in der schweiz
es gab da eine tatsächliche hungersnot
wegen schlechter ernten und man hat die
leute dann mit ein bisschen geld
abgeschrieben damit sie das nächste
schiff in die usa oder nach südamerika
der export von armut ist sicher etwas
was für das neunzehnte jahrhundert eine
wesentliche erleichterung für die
schweiz war und später im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert hat man bei arbeitslosigkeit
ausländische arbeitskräfte zuerst
abgeschoben die schweizer wirtschaft war
immer sehr offen
ausländische unternehmen konnten sich
unbürokratisch ansiedeln und
ausländische arbeitskräfte waren stets
willkommen
jedoch nur so lange sie benötigt wurden
die wirtschaftskrise der 1970 er jahre
beispielsweise wurde abgemeldet in dem
über 200.000 sogenannte gastarbeiter das
land verlassen muss nun zu einem
düsteren kapitel in der schweizer
geschichte das lange nicht aufgearbeitet
wurde
sklaverei das kapital für den aufbau von
einer handelsfirma die dann groß wurde
das kam häufig zb im raum basel bereits
aus investitionen im achtzehnten
jahrhundert die man in den sogenannten
atlantischen dreiecks handel getätigt
hat familien haben sklaven schiffe
ausgerüstet auch sie haben mit sachen
gehandelt die in afrika begehrt waren
und gegen die man dann sklaven
eintauschen konnte und von daher hat die
schweiz eben auch aus diesen
sklavenhandel vorteile gezogen die
familie der bühne zum beispiel aber auch
die familie echte die kaffeepausen auf
kuba hatten und da entstand eben dann
die erste million der familie und wir
wissen die erste million ist die mitte
schwierigste es gibt so die these von
der schweiz als trittbrettfahrerin man
hat einfach immer profitiert von dem was
die großen imperialen mächte weltweit so
angestellt haben also die schweiz hatte
nie die mittel selbst kanonenboote und
große zucken irgendwohin zu schicken
aber andere länder hatten diese mittel
zum beispiel in japan als die usa die
japaner zwangen ihr land zu öffnen als
mit kam rolands war in irland für den
handel westliche firmen zu öffnen
da ist auch eine schweizer delegation
hingereist und hat dann eine
freundschafts und handelsvertrag
abgeschlossen
es scheint als habe die schweiz immer
genau gewusst wo es auf der welt geld zu
verdienen gibt
heute ist die schweiz so reich dass
jeder achte erwachsene dollar millionär
ist aber ist dieser reichtum denn
gerecht verteilt die schweiz hat was die
einkommensverteilung betrifft durchaus
werte die im internationalen vergleich
mit denen sie gut dasteht die
vermögensverteilung ist allerdings sehr
ungleich der gini index misst wie
gerecht oder ungerecht vermögen verteilt
ist der wert 100 ist am schlechtesten
dieser wert würde bedeuten dass einer
einzigen person das gesamte vermögen
eines landes gehört der wert 0 würde
bedeuten dass das vermögen in einem land
unter allen einwohnern absolut
gleichmäßig verteilt ist
die ungerechte vermögensverteilung im
jahre 2009 10 hatten die vereinigten
arabischen emirate mit einem wert von
88,4 ebenfalls ziemlich ungerecht
verteilt war das vermögen in deutschland
und der schweiz
beide mit dem gleich hohen wert von 77,9
etwas gerechter war österreich mit 73,9
die gerechteste vermögensverteilung
aller länder hatte belgien mit 60,2 es
gibt leute auch in der schweiz sehr sehr
wenige leben müssen
das geht dann ländliche regionen wo das
relativ gut geht ihnen steigt dann wir
das sehr schnell prekär dann kann man
einfach nicht mehr am sozialleben
partizipieren und das ist nicht mehr
lustig
wir verdienen mehr als deutsche oder
österreicher aber wir bezahlen noch viel
mehr
die preise sind hier sehr hoch man kann
nicht nur das einkommen anschauen man
muss es mit den lebenshaltungskosten
vergleichen um zu sehen was am ende
übrig bleibt kann man sich in der
schweiz tatsächlich nicht mehr leisten
als in deutschland und österreich das
portal länder info.de hat dies im jahre
2019 berechnet es stützt sich dabei auf
zahlen der oecd und der weltbank
die studie kommt zum schluss dass sich
eine schweizerin ein schweizer im
schnitt elf prozent mehr leisten kann
als ihre nachbarin ihr nachbar in
deutschland
deutschland und österreich sind in etwa
gleichauf trotz der tatsache dass die
schweiz oftmals als hochpreisinsel
angeschaut wird bleibt letztlich den den
schweizern wenn man das
kaufkraftbereinigt anschaut 31.000 euro
circa zur verfügung während in
deutschland das circa 25.000 euro sind
und in österreich 26.000 euro
schweizer können sich also im
durchschnitt tatsächlich mehr leisten
als ihre nachbarn jenseits der grenze
deshalb denken sie ist die schweiz
erreicht ich glaube das liegt so bisher
der bevölkerung dass sie sich auch so
von europa so bisher abkapseln so dass
dennis bestimmten vorteil
ich glaube das verhältnis der schweiz
zur eu ist sekundär für den
wirtschaftlichen erfolg
erstens haben viele sehr reiche leute
das haben wir eine mark niederlande oder
in regionen wie nord italien die sind
auch teile der eu
die sind praktisch gleichwohl zweite
begründung wir sind ja ohnehin schon eng
angebunden an die eu die sinti faktor in
vielen bereichen gerade im
wirtschaftspolitischen bereich sehr eng
verbunden weil es die schweiz der eu
beitreten würde würde sie weder
besonders viel reise nach wie vor augen
ich glaube die situation wäre es
eigentlich was denken sie was ist der
grund wieso die schweiz erreicht ist
warum also die zahlen hier nicht so viel
steuern wie in deutschland
und weil sich da wahrscheinlich auch
sehr viele leute dann hier ansiedeln
in der schweiz wegen den steuern ich
würde mal sagen sie macht schon seit
vier jahren das richtige wenn es darum
geht sich mit dem geld auseinander zu
setzen zum beispiel sei es jetzt die
steuern die steuerbelastung für
unternehmen ist in der schweiz
vergleichsweise tief das
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitut bak
economics hat 2009/10 regionen weltweit
miteinander verglichen demzufolge ergibt
sich in münchen eine steuerbelastung für
unternehmen von 29 3
in wien 22 5 und in basel 11 prozent
eine so tiefe steuerbelastung gibt es in
einigen kantonen der schweiz zb im
kanton zug zu korando agrarischen kanton
bis in die 50er jahre
und das waren dann findige experten aus
ziemlich die eigentlich auf die idee
kommen dass man da ein steuerdumping
installieren könnte um große firmen
anzulocken das waren zuerst
amerikanische firmen
später waren es dann auch russische
firmen die sich hier niedergelassen
haben ja die kommen natürlich hierher
einerseits aus neutralitätsgründen weil
man über die schweiz sehr gut geschäfte
abwickeln kann auch wenn das heimatland
ein embargo gegen einen drittstaat hat
andererseits natürlich aus steuergründen
die drei größten firmen der schweiz sind
rohstoffhandels firmen die schweiz ist
der wichtigste rohstoff handelsplatz der
welt ein viertel aller weltweit
gehandelten rohstoffe werden in der
schweiz abgewickelt
man spricht von transit handel und die
waren kommen nicht in die schweiz
die werden aufgekauft in einem export
land und werden auf der ganzen welt
wieder verkauft das einzige was die
schweiz quasi transit irrt ist das
kapital und das ist ein sehr bedeutendes
geschäft
eben in der schweiz relativ unsichtbar
und braucht ihr eigentlich einen
firmensitz der eingetragen ist eine
adressdatei und eintrifft nicht gut ja
rund 550 solcher handelsfirmen gibt es
in der schweiz nicht zuletzt auch wegen
der neutralität des landes
diese firmen haben dann auch mehrfach
profitiert nach dem ersten nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg oder während der
weltkriege liefen sie zwar immer gefahr
auf die schwarze liste zu kommen wegen
handelns mit dem feind sie haben aber
meist überlebt wurden nicht liquidiert
und konnten dann nach kriegsende aus
ihren gut bestückten lagern immer direkt
wieder liefen auf die schweiz
das ist die schweizer handelsfirmen die
wahren profiteure einig der krise der an
schweizern sich hat nicht so viel
historisches erlebt dadurch natürlich
könnte sich der land sehr schönen
wickeln sie haben sich auch nie
irgendwelche großen kriege eingelöst und
da irgendwie irgendwas verloren oder um
alles was wir hier haben wieder aufbauen
müssen oder unsere vorgänger herr
vorfahren
die haben habt ihr natürlich in der
schweiz nicht so klappt also nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg war die schweiz in
einer relativ guten situation mit
unzerstörten produktionsanlagen
während also die umliegenden länder
durch sind kriegt natürlich sehr
zerstört waren und zum teil auch
deportiert wurden noch dann die anlagen
die es noch gaben dass es in der schweiz
alles nicht passiert also man konnte mit
der produktion anfangen und das war
bedarf an waren da der den die schweiz
unmittelbar nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
sehr schnell erfüllen konnte
[Musik]
die neue tollität war schon wichtig man
hat zu beginn des krieges erklärt man
wolle nicht klickt er umfang teilnehmen
nun heißt das aber nicht dass sein land
nicht trotzdem in den krieg reinkommt
wie man im ersten weltkrieg bei belgien
sah das in der haupt angriffsschlag und
sofort über antwort eine kleine länder
oder kleine regionen die wollen immer
noch klar sein die wohl immer frieden
haben weil sie sehr schwach sind
außenpolitisch und sie haben meist eine
gute wirtschaft und dann ist es glück
sagt man dann dummerweise gerade im weg
steht oder etwas welt ist von den großen
militärischen auseinandersetzungen
[Musik]
essen
warum ist die schweiz erreicht
das könnte die gründe seien keine ahnung
steuerhinterziehung und nazigold deshalb
man also es gibt noch eine these weshalb
die schweiz im zweiten weltkrieg nicht
eingenommen wurde nazi deutschland ist
im krieg zunehmend isoliert und kann mit
seinem geld nirgendwo mehr rohstoffe
kaufen
rohstoffe die auch für die
waffenproduktion benötigt werden
in dieser situation ist die schweiz
nützlich sie fungiert als hehler nimmt
gold von den nazis und tauscht es gegen
schweizer franken ein
es ist gold der deutschen national bank
auf gold dass die deutschen im krieg
erbeuteten und auch gold aus
konzentrationslagern blieb die schweiz
wegen dieser funktion vom krieg
verschont das muss man auch der
zeitliche staffelung sehen in der
kriegsbeginns phase da war dieser
funktion gar noch nicht sichtbar
das war der moment wo die bedrohung am
größten war er wahrgenommen in der
schweiz die schweiz vcs strategischen
toten winkels es passierte nichts und
dann kam schon im sommer 1940 dieses
wirtschaftsabkommen mit deutschland
zustande
und dann kamen diese gold übernommen das
ist keine versicherung gegen einen
angriff aber hat es wohl doch
erleichtert dass deutschland die schweiz
nicht angegriffen hat was sicher
richtige ist ist dass die schweiz
wichtige transaktion durchgeführt hat
aber es ist auch falsch zu sagen die
schweiz sei deshalb nicht erobert worden
und zwar kann man das aus dem vergleich
mit jeder land hatten eine ähnliche
funktion vor 1939 40
sie war sozusagen der finanzplatz
deutschland
das hat sie auch nicht davor bewahrt
dass sie erobert wurden und was was
juden gold anbelangt aus den
konzentrationslagern da ist vielleicht
zum schluss gekommen dass etwas dabei
war
aber für die wirtschaftsgeschichte
spielt das überhaupt keine wesentliche
rolle
die nationalbank spricht lieber über
zahlen als über moral und da ist die
politik weiter sie hat bereits
vorgesorgt wie damals bei kriegsende
will die schweiz mit wohltätigkeit gegen
den schlechten ruf kämpfen 7 milliarden
franken aus der nationalbank sollen in
eine stiftung für solidarität gehen
söhne für nicht über jeden zweifel
erhabene goldgeschäfte der handelnden
zweiten weltkrieg der hat dem renommee
der schweiz natürlich sehr geschadet
also noch 45 waren so das ansehen der
schweiz ziemlich im keller
und da hat man sich dann also mit
neutralität mit hilfsprogrammen mit
hilfsprojekten auch versucht dieses
image des profiteams loszuwerden wieder
denke mal offensichtlich erfolgreich
die neutralität war und ist ein
erfolgsfaktor für die schweiz
dabei war sie gar nicht ihre eigene idee
im neunzehnten jahrhundert wird napoleon
besiegt und europa am wiener kongress
neu geordnet die großmächte können sich
nicht einigen wer die kontrolle über das
alpenland hat
deshalb soll es neutral bleiben
das war eine aufgezwungene neutralität
das ist nicht so dass die schweiz sich
ausgewählt hat dort neutral zu sein aber
sie hat vielleicht diese neutralität
dann benutzt und und hat sie auch zum
eigenen label gemacht
die neutralität ist also nichts originär
schweizerisches ganz im gegensatz zur
direkten demokratie
sie ist weltweit einzigartig
ein instrument der direkten demokratie
ist die volksinitiative alle schweizer
bürger innen haben das recht eine
initiative zu starten schaffen er oder
sie es 100.000 unterschriften zu sammeln
stimmt das volk über das anliegen ab
wenn das volk ja sagt muss das parlament
den entscheid umsetzen dass einer für
die funktion die leute können hier
helfen ihr habt da hat zu wenig gemacht
bitte macht etwas und dadurch gibt es
diese großen polarisierung sind nicht
möglich weil alle irgendwie eingebunden
sind
der vorteil ist ja dass man immer das
volk fragen muss das heißt man muss
immer gut der argumente bringen
es ist schwierig politik zu machen in
der schweiz aber dafür haben wir enorme
stabilität das ist für die wirtschaft
auf jeden fall gut
die kompromissfähigkeit die ihr auch bei
uns im bundesrat leben seit jahrzehnten
vor leben trägt auch zu
stabilität bei es geht nicht um
regierungswechsel sondern es geht um
eine konsensfindung
[Musik]
nicht wie in den meisten ländern üblich
eine regierungschefin oder ein
regierungschef steuern die geschicke des
landes sondern sieben bundesrätinnen aus
vier verschiedenen parteien gemeinsam
[Musik]
so kann nicht ein einzelner plötzliche
oder radikale kurswechsel vornehmen
die politische stabilität wurde uns oft
als grund für den reichtum der schweiz
genannt
gemäß unseren expertinnen wurden schon
bei der gründung der modernen
eidgenossenschaft gute grundlagen dafür
geschaffen
wenn man von der schweiz im neunzehnten
jahrhundert redet muss man sicher von
der bundes staatsgründung von 18 48
sprechen
da entstand die moderne schweiz die sich
dann 18 74 eine total revidierte neue
verfassung gab die die
fortschrittlichste der welt zwar kann
man sagen mit einer direkten demokratie
mit später dann verglich gesetzgebung
dem allgemeinen männer wahlrecht sowieso
sie fragen und lieben allerdings
ausgeschlossen mit der allgemeinen
schulpflicht
[Musik]
natürlich ja bildung spielt er eine
rolle die schulpflicht sollte relativ
früh eingeführt die die der gratis
unterricht war relativ früh das wurden
beide geschlechter und errichtet das hat
man auch damit beliebt gemacht dass in
der schweiz über ganz komplexe fragen
abgestimmt wird und dass darum die
bildung der einfachen leute auch so sein
muss dass sie verstehen was sie da
machen
also das war eines der argumente neben
den wirtschaftlichen faktor sie müssen
rechnen können sie sollen sparen können
sie rollen hausfrauen sollen
haushaltsbücher führen können und all
das das wurde auch gesagt aber es war
auch so dieses allgemeine sie müssen fit
sein damit sie die die staatsgeschäfte
verstehen
beim thema bildung schließt sich in
unserem film dann auch der kreis
zwischen der erfolgreichen vergangenheit
der schweiz und einer erfolgreichen
zukunft
bildung ist der schlüssel zum erfolg
wenn die schweiz weiterhin eine
hochgebildete bevölkerung hat mit einem
hohen grad an kompetenz für
zukunftsberufe dann wird sie an der
spitze der oecd länder bleiben und ist
weiterhin innovativ und wettbewerbsfähig
was ich aber heute sehr beunruhigt mich
die ungleiche verteilung von reichtum
führt dazu dass das thema bildung etwas
weniger beachtung bekommt bildung sollte
die oberste priorität haben also die
schweiz sollte ihr ganzes vermögen in
die aus und weiterbildung der
bevölkerung steckt aber das passiert
nicht
ich glaube einfach dass diese
alleinstellungsmerkmale tendenziell
weniger wichtig werden oder die
amerikaner wissen unterdessen auch wie
man beim king macht und kann sich nicht
mehr so einfach auf ein spezialgebiet
[Musik]
konzentrieren und das den anderen
verkaufen
wir haben jedoch auch wenn sich jetzt
etwas verändert aber immer noch einen
sehr breiten wohlstand als eine doch
relativ breite partizipation am
wohlstand und daher sicher nicht die die
schlechtesten bedingungen aber das hängt
alles davon ab wie sich die schweiz
jetzt international positioniert und ob
sie da auf eine neben kluge ort mit
macht die führenden branchen die zeit
nehmen auch wohin der erfolg geht und im
moment sieht was sind die größten am
schnellsten wachsen erfolgreichen
unternehmen das sind sozusagen eine
daten unternehmen
tech unternehmen
[Musik]
in zukunft wird der wettbewerb nicht nur
sein wären meisten daten hat sondern
wäre sozusagen die besten programme hat
die diese daten verarbeiten also es geht
um künstliche intelligenzen und
diesbezüglich ist die schweiz nicht im
spitzenfeld auch in europa werden
künstliche intelligenzen entwickeln auch
in europa wird geforscht aber im
vergleich auch zum marktmacht in usa und
asien ist europa klar im hintertreffen
es gibt viele schweizer oder in der
schweiz lebende menschen die gute ideen
haben in bezug auf den global innovation
index sind wir auf platz eins wir sind
vor den usa umgesetzt wird es dann
vielleicht oft ein bisschen zu weniger
aber die ideen die forschungsideen die
sind da spiel überzeugt dass die schweiz
weiterhin sehr attraktiv und stark sein
wird wirtschaftlich der einfachste
indikator ist die einwanderung wenn ein
land so viel einwanderung hat die
schweiz zwar auf allen ebenen sozusagen
vom zielpunkt qualifizierten gesagt
weniger qualifiziert dann ist
offensichtlich mache sie sehr vieles
richtig und die länder die das nicht
haben bei den muss man sich sorgen noch
aber die schweiz ist so begehrt
dadurch komme nie wieder sehr gute leute
in die schweiz ich habe überhaupt keine
sorge
es ist die fortsetzung der alten
geschichte
viele meinungen zu zukunft und
vergangenheit der schweiz
worüber sich die expertinnen und
experten einig sind
die schweiz hatte durch ihre
geographische lage gute
ausgangsbedingungen
dann kamen glück und ideenreichtum dazu
clevere politische entscheide und eine
prise schamlosigkeit
[Musik]
und es gilt wo der alte regel geld
fließt zu geld
[Musik]
[Gelächter]